Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlav und es ist Freitag und das heißt es gibt wieder,
Ein wöchentliches Update zur Koronakrise, sprich ein Korona Weeky mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pabel.
Hallo Tim. Und heute ist der siebenundzwanzigste November.
So sieht es aus oder auch KW achtundvierzig kommt zum Ende, das sind alles so.
Zahlen, die man sich sonst nicht so wach macht, aber die ganz praktisch sein können. Eine Interpretation all dieser ganzen Datenmengen, die auf einen äh zugerollt kommen. Na ja und um diese Datenmengen mal wieder ein wenig auseinanderzunehmen.
Haben wir uns wieder zusammengefunden,
Allerdings finde ich, sollten wir kurz äh ein aufs Feedback der letzten Sendung eingehen und wo ich gleich nach Veröffentlichung der Sendung äh konfrontiert wurde, war natürlich absolut berechtigt. Ich habe mich nämlich
Bei der ganzen, bei dem ganzen Hin und Her, mit den Zahlen und den Anteilen und den Permillions und so weiter völlig äh verrant,
Und ich glaube, das war dann, als wir über Belgien gesprochen haben, wo ich dann meinte, dass irgendwie mittlerweile ein Prozent
der Bevölkerung irgendwie ein Unsinn gewesen, denn in dem Moment blickte ich auf die Permillionzahl und das
kriegt man halt schnell durcheinander, weil eben diese ganzen Institenzen immer alle per hunderttausend sind. Und habe dann das eine mit dem anderen äh zusammengeworfen,
Also selbstverständlich, wenn man in den tausender Zahlen ist bei Permilien, dann ist es natürlich ein Promille. Von daher ist dann erst ein Promille gestorben, ihr könnt euch erstmal wieder beruhigen,
Nur jeder Tausendste äh ist gestorben. Ähm,
Ja gut, aber nichtsdestotrotz äh sind die Zahlen ausreichend beunruhigt, beunruhigt gewesen und das werden wir ja auch gleich sehen, wenn wir hier die Todeszahlen in Deutschland,
durchdeklinieren oder vielleicht auch in anderen Ländern, das ist alles andere äh als Grund zur Entwarnung gibt.
Hinweis war dann in den Kommentaren. Auch da geht's um Zahlen, Verwirrung und zwar schreibt Kilo Sierra.
Nochmal kurze Diskussionsgrundlage. Ich habe mir heute mal den Spaß gemacht für unseren Landkreis, die online verfügbaren sieben Tagesinstitenzen rauszusuchen und bin fast rückwärts vorm Stuhl gefallen, um es dazu sagen, leider wird hier nicht erwähnt, um welchen Landkreis es handelt, deswegen können wir das gerade nur sehr begrenz
ähm untersuchen, aber.
Werden verschiedene Quellen angegeben mit äh entsprechenden.
Sieben Tagesinstiten, also Corona RKI DE sagt dreiundvierzig Komma vier
das Gesundheitsamt des Landkreises sagt hundertdreiundfünfzig Komma zwei, das Sozialministerium des Landes spricht von dreiundsiebzig Komma zwei,
eine Tabelle äh sagte zu dem Zeitpunkt hundertdreißig Komma fünf.
Ist aber noch nicht mal der höchste Wert, sondern da gibt's noch die süddeutsche DE, die mit hundertvierundsechzig Komma zwei und Zeit DE, die mit hundertneunundfünfzig Komma drei äh,
an die Front gehen.
Weiter schreibt er oder sie die beiden Online-Portale behaupten beide sich auf die AKI Zahlen null Uhr zu beziehen, bei den öffentlichen Stellen stand auch jedes Mal Stand vierundzwanzigster elfter dabei.
Wer will denn auf so einer Grundlage Entscheidung treffen? Da braucht man auch nicht mehr über irgendwelche Effekte aus der Teststrategie zu diskutieren, wenn schon das einfache Kopieren einer Zahl zur nächsten Datenbank offensichtlich nicht ohne Genauigkeitsverlust möglich ist.
Ja, ja, die schönen sieben Tages.
Institutionen. Es wurde auch zu Recht äh jetzt von verschiedenen Leuten auf Twitter gefordert, dass wenn doch
Jetzt sagen gesetzliche Maßnahmen an Institzberechnungen gekoppelt sind, dass man das doch dann doch vielleicht auch spezifiziert, wie denn diese Instituzen äh zu berechnen
sind
und da steckt dann der Teufel im Detail, aber ich kann's äh versuchen, mal ein bisschen zu beleuch.
Die niedrigen Zahlen, die auf Corona, RKI DE ausgewiesen sind.
Den
Zahlen, äh, an denen Neuinfektionen, die in den letzten sieben Tagen beim RKI gemeldet wurden und
wo sich aber die Leute auch innerhalb der letzten sieben Tage beim Gesundheitsamt gemeldet haben. Das heißt,
landen wir schon sehr oft hier bei den offiziellen RKI-Zahlen
In dem Moment, wo die Gesundheitsämter etwas langsamer arbeiten oder das Testen etwas langer äh länger dauert, fallen halt Fälle unterm Tisch
Also wenn's nicht innerhalb von sieben Tagen von Meldung beim Gesundheitsamt diese Infektion beim RKI eingeht, geht die auch nicht mehr in die Zahl ein und auch nicht später oder so, die ist weg.
So. Ähm die Gesundheitsämter in der Regel nehmen halt.
Ihre Zahlen, die sie, die sie haben und selbst wenn die jetzt sieben Tage Grenze ansetzen, wie das vielleicht das Sozialministerium macht,
sind die zeitlich ein bisschen früher dran, so ein, zwei, drei Tage, je nachdem hat das Gesundheitsamt
Zahlen bevor das RKI die Zahlen bekommt insofern selbst wenn die 'ne sieben Tage Cut Off machen fallen dann nicht so viele Fälle unter den Tisch,
ich mache auf Pabel Meier DE,
einen vierzehn Tages Cut-Off für das Meldedatum beim Gesundheitsamt,
aus dem einfachen Grund, dass ich mir dachte, naja gut, die sieben Tage sind einfach zu knapp, da fallen dann teilweise bis zu siebzig Prozent äh äh unterm Tisch, wie wir es jetzt haben und ich habe
deswegen auch in der letzten Woche eine extra Spalte eingeführt, wie viel beim RKI unter den Tisch äh fällt und ähm.
Und der vierzehn Tages Cut off fand ich so ein bisschen das Beste aus beiden Welten, weil nämlich manchmal auch Meldungen, haufenweise nach drei, vier, fünf, sechs Wochen,
eingehen aus irgendwelchen Gründen äh bleiben Fälle stecken und kommen erst halt sehr, sehr viel später. Die.
Wenn man jetzt gar kein Cut-Off macht, dann hat man dann wieder eine Verfälschung manchmal in manchen Landkreisen äh mit Altfällen, die aber gar nicht mehr dann wirklich
in die sieben Tagesinstitenz eingehen sollten und,
Ja so erklären sich halt die Unterschiede und ich nehme mal an, dass die Süddeutsche einfach die veröffentlichten Zahlen nimmt und gar kein Cut-Off macht, deswegen liegen die bei mir höher, dann.
Unter Umständen und dass sie sich äh vielleicht auch noch äh,
Daten aus anderen Quellen verwenden und möglicherweise die einzelnen äh,
Länderveröffentlichung scrapen, wo man dann auch zeitlich vielleicht nochmal ein, zwei Tage oder so äh zeitlich gewinnen kann. Und so ähm,
kommen diese Unterschiede zustande. Ähm ja,
Ich halte natürlich meine Variante für die Beste, weil sonst hätte ich äh sie nicht gewählt, weil sie so ein bisschen einerseits
ja da nicht so viele Fälle unter den Tisch fallen bei den vierzehn Tagen,
man halt
Jahr nicht die Verzerrungen durch die ganz alten Fälle hat, wenn irgendwie jemand einen erkrankter Gesundheits mit
Arbeiter dann nach drei Wochen oder so zur Arbeit zurückkommt und dann den den Schrank mit den Akten, äh, die dann liegen geblieben sind vielleicht
äh fertig arbeitet oder so ähnlich. Und äh ja in dem Zusammenhang, ich meine, erinnerst du dich.
An äh die Bilder, die wir mal diskutiert hatten aus dem Gesundheitsamt oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir es in der Sendung hatten,
die Soldaten zu sehen waren, die in Berlin auf dem Gesundheitsamt arbeiten und dann saßen da zwanzig Leute, so wirklich dicht nebeneinander,
so sechs Leute an einem Tisch, also von Abstand konnte da nun wirklich nicht die Rede sein.
Masken.
Ohne Masken,
und äh jetzt kamen halt neulich Meldungen, dass in manchen Landkreisen sämtliche Mitarbeiter äh des Gesundheitsamts an Kovit erkrankt sind,
So das äh finde ich natürlich schon extrem heftig. Also das,
ich glaube äh dass das war irgendwo Görlitz äh oder so, die die Ecke da unten,
Einer der Landkreise mit.
Auch extrem hohen Inzidenzen, aber äh ist nur anekdotisch.
Aber ich halte das, also nach den Bildern, die ich gesehen habe, halte ich das für absolut äh realistisch. Vermutlich auch an anderen Stellen im öffentlichen Dienst. Weil einfach die Raumausstattung so miserabel äh ist vielerorts.
Und ja.
Man da und wenn da nicht ein Chef ist, der ein bisschen auf Draht und auf Zack ist und äh ja, sondern,
nur.
Mit dem agiert, was was da ist und nicht einfach mal vielleicht irgendwo ein neues Gebäude requiriert, äh dann ja hocken auf einmal vielleicht sogar noch doppelt so viele Leute mit Verstärkung
in in Büros, äh wo sie sich unmöglich schützen können. Na ja, egal, kleiner.
Äh zwischen äh Rand aber ähm,
ansonsten aber hatte ich anlässlich dessen auch nochmal auf die süddeutsche geguckt und die haben in der Tat 'ne ganz schöne Korona Seite muss ich sagen mit einer Menge informativen Grafiken
auch also kann ich sagen wir auch empfehlen. Ähm dieses Portal.
Hilft schon, wenn man ein paar Leute dabei hat, die so Visualisierung äh ordentlich können.
Überhaupt dann finde ich ist das ja äh der der finale Push so für Datenjournalismus.
Kann mich noch erinnern, wie dieser Begriff vor,
vier, fünf Jahren, gefühlt.
Haupt erstmal aufkam so und diese ganze Vorstellung von.
Haar-Journalisten sollen die sich jetzt irgendwie Daten selber reinziehen und das selber visualisieren und so, warum denn?
Da gab's ja dann viel äh Skepsis, dann gab's auch so einige Pilotprojekte an manchen Zeitungen, dann war das mal so ein so ein kurzer Hype, bei dem einen hat's ein bisschen besser funktioniert, bei den anderen weniger,
Ich denke, dass es das Thema ist jetzt mit der Pandemie dann auch mal komplett durch, dass man sowas braucht, ne? Das ist einfach zur Interpretation von Situationen, Sinnzahlen,
einfach sehr sehr sehr wichtig und gerade diese dieses Beispiel jetzt hier mit den.
Unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen, ja, die alle ja letztlich versuchen eigentlich den selben Wert festzumachen für eine relativ klar definierten
geografischen Bereich zeigt, dass
eben auch ein Verständnis über Algorithmen und Datenakquise und Datenauswertung und Regeln und so weiter geführt werden muss und dass wir natürlich in dem Zuge auch in Zukunft
Standardisierungswesen etablieren müssen in.
Deutschland, dass äh einfach klar macht, wie wird mit Zahl berechnet, ja? Also wirklich genau so und das das äh.
Quasi wie es Gesetze gibt, gibt es eben auch entsprechende,
standardisierte Vorschriften für solche Sachen. Nur nur dann kann man sowas verhindern, es wird dann immer noch,
ein oder andere aus dem Bruder laufen. Aber ist auf jeden Fall besser als jetzt dieser Wildwuchs, den wir jetzt haben.
Weil die nächste Schwierigkeit kommt dann zum Beispiel bei der sieben Tage R Wertberechnung, weil äh da
wird's dann sozusagen basierend auf diesen Zahlenchaos, wenn man dann jetzt noch draufsetzt, kann man dann den R-Wert auch nach, ich sage mal, auch vier, fünf verschiedenen Verfahren berechnen
äh
wo man dann auch zu leicht unterschiedlichen äh Ergebnissen kommt, die aber natürlich auch entscheidend sein können. Also wenn man jetzt RWT abhängige Gesetzgebung zum Beispiel macht.
Ja, ein Ampelsysteme und.
Dann schauen wir doch mal auf die Zahlen von Deutschland der letzten Woche, was konntest du denn da feststellen.
Ja, wir haben im Wesentlichen eine komplette Seitwärts,
Bewegung seit einer Woche mit sagen jetzt,
minimalen Rückgang im äh um weniger als ein Prozent äh,
nicht sagen im im Wochenmittel und äh ja also dementsprechend
liegt auch jetzt seit
etwa zehn Tagen der äh sieben Tage RWT äh ziemlich genau bei eins so da äh tut sich
Moment nicht viel, weil auch dazu gesagt, mein Airwert äh an dem ich jetzt rede. Ähm,
basiert auf den Veröffentlichten,
ähm Zahlen, also nicht äh auf äh wie das RKI das etwa macht äh
auf den Zahlen und den den Meldezahlen ist und so dass sich der Wert beim RKI im Nachhinein ändern kann,
wenn mehr Daten reinkommen.
Aber all diese ganzen Ehrwerte liegen einfach äh so nah beieinander, dass man da jetzt eh nicht groß unterscheiden muss.
Ja äh also.
Kann einfach sagen die Zahl der Infektionen so hat sich nicht wesentlich verändert in den letzten zehn Tagen,
und äh dementsprechend ja muss äh der R-Wert äh halt irgendwo bei eins liegen. Knapp.
Unter eins, knapp über eins. Also ich habe so zwischen, ich sage mal, null Komma neun acht und eins Komma null zwei. Äh also schwankt auch äh sehr, sehr wenig.
Hal.
Drei Wochen lang, eigentlich stetig gefallen ist. So, sogar, ja.
Dreieinhalb Wochen lang ist er runtergegangen und seit zehn Tagen stagniert er jetzt.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt das Datum äh heranziehen, ist das so quasi die ja, die äh Verabschiedung und Ankündigung eines Lokdownlights, das war ja am dritten November oder was der zweite, ich weiß nicht mehr genau
zweiter dritter November.
Hat dann was zur Folge gehabt, das war auch erstmal ganz positiv, aber es die Maßnahmen ziehen einfach nicht genug, um's wirklich jetzt alles zu reduzieren.
Ja war auch der Fuckup war, dass man halt zeitgleich fa.
Einführung der Maßnahmen am zweiten elften am glaube fünften elften.
Die neue Teststrategie eingeführt hat.
So dass die Testzahlen ab KW sechsundvierzig auch vom RKI mit einem Stern versehen werden, die ab dritten November zwanzig zwanzig geänderte Testkriterien, Daten nicht direkt mit Vorwochen vergleichbar.
Super, oder?
Das ausgerechnet, wenn wir irgendwie Smonitoring brauchen und gerne wissen wollten, wie wirken sich denn eigentlich jetzt die Maßnahmen aus?
Ändern wir die ganzen Regeln, sodass wir jetzt zwei oder drei Wochen lang,
keine äh wirklich vergleichbaren Zahlen äh haben
Dennoch äh kann man aus den Zahlen äh Schlüsse ziehen und zwar.
Was halt passiert ist, dass äh in KW sechsundvierzig und siebenundvierzig, aber vor allem äh sagen von fünfundvierzig auf auf sechsundvierzig hat die Zahl der Tests um über dreizehn Prozent.
Genommen, so. Natürlich kann man auch ausgehen, wenn du dreizehn Prozent weniger Tests äh machst, würdest du bei gleicher Institz dreizehn Prozent weniger positive Fälle.
Kriegen so übern äh gesagt. Ähm stattdessen äh so.
Ähm gab's aber nur null Komma acht Prozent weniger äh,
Fälle, also dreizehn Prozent weniger Tests, null Komma acht Prozent.
Weniger davon waren positiv so. Das heißt, die damit ist halt die positiven äh äh Rate äh ist halt äh dann ja nochmal von sieben Komma acht fünf auf neun Prozent gestiegen.
Kurz gesagt ähm.
Die Zahl der Tests ist zurückgegangen und die positiven Quote äh ist gestiegen in den letzten beiden Wochen.
Was äh und äh die Zahlen sind halt weitgehend gleich geblieben.
Also heißt das, wenn jetzt die positiven äh Quote gestiegen ist, ist auch die Dunkelziffer äh Quote gestiegen, das heißt unsere Zahlen unterschätzen in den letzten zwei Wochen, die tatsächliche,
Ausbreitung der Infektion, das heißt sie sind ein bisschen zu,
so mit anderen Worten Zahlen sagen R ungefähr
in Wirklichkeit,
hätte man jetzt die Testkriterien nicht geändert und die Zahl der Tests wie notwendig ausgeweitet wären die Infektionen in den letzten beiden Wochen äh weiter gestiegen,
Im Übrigen habe ich gelesen, empfiehlt die Weltgesundheitsorganisation die positiven Quote nicht über fünf Prozent steigen zu lassen, so um äh das Ausmaß der Infektion
noch einigermaßen erfassen äh zu können. Wir sind jetzt bei neun Komma drei neun, das heißt noch nach WHO-Kriterien testen wir im Moment zu wenig.
Welche Zahl siehst du gerade als die aktuelle an? Also bei Our World and Data sind wir bei neun Komma.
Drei neun hab ich.
Fünf, ja war so in dem, in dem Boypark. Äh ich kann das jetzt nur mit Hour World and Data vergleichen. Der höchste Wert, den wir in dieser positiven Quote äh bisher hatten,
vom fünften April zwanzig zwanzig, also sozusagen mitten im ersten, fetten Lokdown und da lag er bei neun Komma sechs Prozent.
Ja, ich habe ich habe hier die Tabelle unten äh bei den bei den Deutschland äh Zahlen für die Woche, das ist sozusagen die offizielle Tabelle vom RKI.
Da wird,
KW vierzehn, das muss das gewesen sein. Neu waren neun Komma null drei bisher der höchste Wert und jetzt sind wir bei neun Komma drei neun, also.
Okay, also in der Skala sogar noch höher. Also mit anderen Worten wir testen deutlich,
wenig, wir sehen das Geschehen nicht. Die Zahlen, die wir jetzt haben, sind an sich schon beunruhigend, aber wir wissen auch, dass sie nicht stimmen.
Ja. Ähm genau, ich meine jetzt von KW sechsundvierzig auf siebenundvierzig hat sich zumindest die Zahl der Tests einigermaßen äh stabilisiert. Ist halt leicht, um.
Zwei Komma acht Prozent zurückgegangen nochmal. Äh ja, leichter Rückgang, aber eben Anstieg der der positiven äh Quote,
genau eins Komma fünf Prozent mehr Infektion trotz Rückgang der Tests und.
Vier Komma fünf Prozent mehr positiven Quote. Kurz gesagt, die Ausbreitung der Infektion ist,
fast gestoppt. Äh die Zahlen sind alle ein bisschen zu positiv und suggerieren einen leichten Rückgang während äh tatsächlich äh mal von einem leichten Anstieg äh ausgehen.
Musste, real.
Ach so, ja und die Zahl der Toten ist jetzt auf einem absoluten Rekordniveau, also seit zwei Tagen
sieben Tagesdurchschnitt hat jetzt den sieben Tagesdurchschnitt der ersten Welle,
bundesweit überschritten. In Berlin war das schon länger der Fall, weil Berlin bis in der ersten Welle ein bisschen glimpflicher davon gekommen,
als der Bund aber ja.
Was war jetzt die aktuelle Todeszahl, die jetzt zuletzt veröffentlicht wurde.
Ähm also im sieben Tagesdurchschnitt sind's zweihundertachtzig.
Und heute Deutschland.
Waren's glaube ich über vierhundert, ne?
Weit äh vierhundertsechsundzwanzig.
Vierhundertsechsundzwanzig.
Ja, alle vor allem dreihundertneunundachtzig davor vierhundertzehn. Ah, die vierhundertsechsundzwanzig ist damit.
Auch 'n absoluter neuer Tagesrekord, so viel.
Gab's noch nie so viel Tote an einem Tag,
ja und ich kann dann auch nochmal vielleicht wenn's interessiert sagen.
In welchen Altersgruppen äh.
Die Zahl mal zu verdeutlichen, vierhundertsechsundzwanzig Leute an einem Tag heißt alle dreieinhalb Minuten stirbt jemand an dieser Krankheit. In Deutschland.
Aber in der Altersgruppe fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig haben wir drei Todesfälle.
Unter den vierhundertsechsundzwanzig.
Wir haben in der Altersgruppe fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig haben wir fünfzehn Tote.
Altersgruppe sechzig bis neunundsiebzig.
Sind es hundertvierzehn.
Stieg nämlich in den letzten Wochen halt fast stetig an, deswegen,
Ja, also hundertvierzehn und das Gro der Todesfälle war in der Gruppe Altersgruppe achtzig Plus,
wo es, äh, sie hat zweihundertdreiundneunzig Fälle gab. Und ich find gerade immerhin in der Altersgruppe,
finde ich es besonders traurig, dass da halt viele Leute drunter sind, die sich selber gar nicht schützen konnten, ne, die keine Chance hat
weil sie ja
pflegebedürftig sind und da in Heim leben und darauf angewiesen sind, dass hal,
beziehungsweise die Heime diese Menschen schützt und ganz offensichtlich
klappt das nicht, ja? Und das kla,
in einem Ausmaß nicht äh so
sagen kann, äh ja mittlerweile neunundsechzigtausendsiebenhundertvierundvierzig Menschen über achtzig Jahre haben sich bisher infiziert,
und gestorben äh insgesamt in der Alters äh Gruppe zehntausendeinhunderteinundsiebzig.
Also über mittlerweile jetzt über zehntausend alte Menschen, die.
Glaube ab achtzig kann man jemanden, glaube ich, berechtigt als alt bezeichnen. Bei den sechzig bis neunundsiebzigjährigen würde ich sagen, ist man heutzutage noch nicht wirklich alt oder viele sind noch nicht wirklich alt.
Und äh ja, in der in der Altersgruppe der nicht wirklich alten Warns.
Immerhin viertausendsechshundertvierundachtzig Toolsfälle. Also es.
Auch eine Menge. Mal sagen, eine Menge Leute, die.
Da offensichtlich dann deren Lebensabend deutlich verkürzt wurde oder die wahrscheinlich vielleicht sogar aus dem Beruf gerissen wurde.
Wie verteilt sich denn das jetzt auf die Bundesländer? Was haben wir denn da.
In den Bundesländern,
Die Inzidenz insgesamt am höchsten ist in Sachsen und dann Berlin, Thüringen, Bayern, das ist so die.
Reihenfolge und Sachsen und Berlin liegen.
Zweihundertneunundvierzig und zweihundertvierundzwanzig Fällen,
neuen Fällen je hunderttausend Einwohner und ja Thüringen und Bayern sind,
beim Bayern bei hundertneunzig, Thüringen, bei hundertneunundfünfzig und so weiter. Ähm die einzigen beiden Bundesländer, die gerade knapp unter den fünfzig liegen, werden Schleswig-Holstein und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Interessant ist es zumindest sechs Bundesländer gibt, wo die Zahlen trotz der Unterschätzung gestiegen sind.
In den sieben sogar,
und in neun äh Bundesländern sind sie gefallen und am stärksten sehe ich im Saarland und in äh Bremen und in Hamburg.
Aber muss man, wie gesagt, alles mit Vorsicht genießen und auch im im.
Bundesschnitt,
ja, es ist weniger als ein Prozent äh Rückgang. Äh bei der sieben Tages äh Institz, also auch an diese Zahl nicht nur der Graf, die stimmen alle überein, dass wir uns seitlich bewegen.
Heißt so viel wie eigentlich tut sich nichts.
Eigentlich äh tut sich nichts und ich habe ja, ach genau, ich habe in der letzten Woche auch nochmal.
Geguckt,
welches R wir brauchten ja die die auch in der letzten äh Sendung schon mal erwähnt, das habe ich dann auch nochmal auf Twitter ein bissch,
zahlenmäßig ausgeführt, äh die
Studie ausm Landset, wo hunderteinunddreißig Länder geguckt worden
ist wie versenken denn einzelne Maßnahmen des R und.
Äh da war kurz gesagt, alle äh dort getesteten Maßnahmen können es refähren halbieren und einzelne Maßnahmen äh bringen, so die besseren zwischen zehn und zwanzig Prozent weniger.
Und jetzt,
ist die Frage so wie viel R haben wir gewonnen und seit dem Höhepunkt,
vor vier Wochen haben wir ungefähr fünfundzwanzig Prozent weniger R.
Aber sagt seit zehn Tagen äh passiert da nichts mehr und wenn sich das so fortsetzt, ist klar, werden sich die werden die Zahlen auch nicht runtergehen, wird das halt auf dem.
Niveau bleiben und äh,
Zahl der Toten wird noch hochgehen, das heißt, wir werden dann jede Woche, weiß ich nicht, drei bis dreihundert, vierhundert Tote haben auf nicht absehbare Zeit, also über,
Wochen und Monate hinweg, wenn sich nichts ändert, aber es wird sich was ändern. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass äh die Zahlen.
Eins bleiben, sondern die werden in die eine oder andere Richtung auswandern, definitiv. Und die Frage jetzt.
Was bräuchten wir denn, wie viel, wie viel Gewinn beim R müssten wir uns eigentlich noch einhandeln und je nachdem wie viel Area dann,
holen und da ist es so, dass.
Wenn wir einen R von null Komma acht hätten, also zwanzig Prozent gegenüber dem, was wir jetzt haben.
Geschafft hätten, muss man äh sagen, dann würden wir in sehr, sehr kurzer Zeit, also in.
Prinzip einem Monat, also weniger als einem Monat bundesweit unter die null Komma fünf,
kommen. Also einen drei dreiwöchiger Logdown, äh der äh ja den er auf null Komma acht bringt. Ähm sagen,
ermöglicht dann wieder über weiteres Öffnen nachzudenken. Bei null Komma acht fünf ist es dann ungefähr, dauert's nochmal zehn Tage länger bei null Komma neun ungefähr einen Monat.
Also da werden wir dann schon Mitte Januar und bei null Komma neun fünf was
ja sind wir im Februar, bis wir über also sind wir Ende Februar angekommen bis wir über Lockerungen nachdenken können und alles
über null Komma neun fünf so,
im Schnitt, äh, da werden wir vor dem Sommer keine Lockerungen sehen, ja? So, also das macht sei es, wir müssen eigentlich,
müssten wir mindestens zehn Prozent beim beim R äh rausholen oder wenigstens die fünf Prozent äh das wäre dann zwar immer noch bitter,
Ja, so sieht, so sieht halt,
bei der bei der zeitlichen Prognose aus und,
kriegen wir die fünf Prozent nach unten,
noch vorher und wenn ja, woher sollen die kommen, oder? Kriegen wir vielleicht fünf Prozent nach oben und ja
fünf Prozent,
nach oben würde die Zahlen durch die Decke schießen lassen. Da werden wir dann bis Jahresende würde sich die Institenz verdoppelt haben gegenüber dem, wenn's nur um fünf Prozent
jetzt nach oben geht die Ansteckungsrate, also wie man sieht ist diese Pandimie extrem sensitiv gegenüber.
Kleineren Veränderungen bei der, bei der Ansteckungsquote. Wenn man sich in der Situation befindet, wo wir uns befinden, nämlich das R um eins,
herumliegt, weil da hat man keine wir haben keine Reserve nirgendwo hin und wir haben auch eigentlich keine Wahl,
können nur nach unten, weil wenn wir nach weiter nach oben gehen, dann selbst nur ein bisschen, dann kommt unser Gesundheitssystem an die Grenzen. Auf dem Level, wie es jetzt ist,
würde es zwar ja äh um auch einen hohen Preis fordern, aber vermutlich,
also würde das Gesundheitssystem das durchhalten. Sagen wenn's auf dem Niveau.
Weiterlaufen würde äh und Zahlen nicht weiter steigen.
Also durchhalten im Sinne von die eigentlich jetzt schon nicht gute Überbelastung würde durchgehend beibehalten, sagen wir es mal so, ne?
Ja? Und es würden zigtausend Leute absehbar sterben. Also die Zahl,
wir haben ja jetzt eine A.
Absolute Zahl an Todesfällen äh kommuniert zweiundzwanzigtausend.
Fünfzehntausend sorry fünfzehn Tau.
Fünfzehntausendfünfhundertsechsundachtzig sehe ich.
Und diese Zahl würde sich dann in den nächsten
Monaten auf vierzig, fünfzig, sechzigtausend äh hochbewegen, ja. Also in den nächsten zwei Monaten äh würden äh mehr Menschen äh sterben als bisher
insgesamt in Deutschland während der gesamten Pandemie, wenn die Zahlen nicht nach unten gehen, wenn's so bleibt, wie es ist.
Tja, da kann sich keiner so richtig drüber freuen. Ich meine, das das kann man jetzt glaube ich auch nicht oft genug sagen, also äh wir werden ja gleich noch über die Maßnahmen sprechen, aber man kann, glaube ich, jetzt an dieser Stelle schon mal festhalten. Dieser Lokdownlight.
Das hat eine Wirkung gezeigt, aber nicht ansatzweise eine Wirkung, die jetzt in irgendeiner Form an eine Position bringt,
dass wir diesen Logdownlight so verlassen könnten. Also es ist einfach lockerer als das, geht eigentlich gar nicht. Na wie gut, dass dann gerade Weihnachten kommt und alle wieder Probleme haben, Leute zu beschränken.
Mhm. Also gut, wenn man jetzt guckt okay was,
kann jetzt den sagen welche Kräfte oder welche Veränderungen könnten jetzt R äh nach oben oder nach unten.
Bringen und da und.
Bei den meisten wissen wir es nicht so genau, aber erstmal kommt man ja sehen, dass die Maßnahmen, wenn man sie einführt, so etwa nach.
Drei Wochen, manche nach vier Wochen, aber in der Größenordnung erreichen sie den Höhepunkt ihrer Wirkung. Bei sehr vielen Maßnahmen ist es so, dass sie den sogar früher erreichen
und dann langsam verpuffen, also beispielsweise Kontaktbeschränkung irgendwann werden die Leute äh halt,
ja offensichtlich isolationsmüde und fangen dann wieder an, sich mehr zu treffen. Ja, so unvorsichtiger oder auch bei Grenzschließungen hat man festgestellt,
wenn die Grenzen zu sind, reisen die Leute erstmal nicht, aber bei vielen staut sich dann offenbar nach,
paar Wochen das Bedürfnis oder der Drang
dann doch unbedingt die Reise machen zu müssen oder sie finden illegal Wege ohne Quarantäne dann zu reisen, sodass festgestellt hat, dass halt Reise äh Beschränkungen, äh die wir ja
in dem Sinne noch nicht mal wirklich haben
sondern nur so indirekt durch das private Unterkünfte nicht zulässig sind, aber Leute, wenn sie sagen sie sind beruflich unterwegs, dann können sie trotzdem noch in einem Hotel
unterkommen, also insofern ist das alles sehr sehr löchrig.
So, das heißt, was die bisherigen Maßnahmen angeht, ist nicht zu erwarten, äh dass,
sich deren Wirkung noch weiter verstärkt, sondern da sind wir entweder jetzt oder in spätestens in der Woche wahrscheinlich auf einem Plateau,
angelangt. Deswegen war ja, war eigentlich der vergangene Mittwoch mit.
Den neuen Maßnahmen oder Planungen so.
Wichtig äh eigentlich und ähm vielleicht sollten wir jetzt doch einfach durch die Maßnahmen gehen, weil das die passende Stelle ist, nämlich um halt auch zu gucken, okay, äh was ist denn, was ist denn jetzt zu erwarten äh von den Maßnahmen
und mein, sondern vielleicht aber auch noch sagen kann, ähm gut Weihnachten haben wir faktisch,
Durch die Weihnachtsferien haben wir auch Schulschließungen so, das heißt, wir haben zumindest jetzt quasi ja die Politik mehr oder weniger um kostenlos in Anführungszeichen äh zwei bis drei Wochen Schul,
Schließungen mit drin, die einen positiven Einfluss.
Haben könnten auf das Infektionsgeschehen.
Alles andere so sehe ich,
eher dass das Infektionsgeschehen nach oben äh bringen könnte. Gut, vielleicht noch auch, dass Leute nicht nicht arbeiten, das heißt, das also Schulschließung und äh äh Leute arbeiten weniger ähm,
Viele haben Urlaub, das könnte auch noch eventuell,
äh er sinken, aber alles andere, also wir haben.
Kälteres Wetter zu erwarten, kälteres und nasseres Wetter. Das wird sicherlich äh,
nicht runterbringen, sondern möglicherweise äh sogar nach oben bringen.
Und dann haben wir natürlich vorweihnachtliche Shoppingaktivitäten die äh Ertenziell,
eher nach oben bringen und dann haben wir die zu erwartenden Weihnachtsfeiertage und das Weihnachtsfest und wie sagt irgendwie ein amerikanischer
Virologe, der jetzt anlässlich Senksgewinn vor Reisen gewarnt hat, wenn Leute reisen, reißt das Virus mit.
Zu, das fand ich irgendwie ganz gut auf den äh Punkt gebracht. Also ich sage mal jetzt,
von den Erwartungen her, würde ich sagen, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
eigentlich höher das Ero steigt
als dass es fällt. Beides ist möglich, so wir haben viel genug Überraschungen erlebt, aber so jetzt wenn man rational drüber nachdenkt und sagt, was sind jetzt die Kräfte, die das beeinflussen? Dann sehe ich eher
im Dezember steigende Zahlen auf uns zukommen. So und jetzt ist die Frage ähm weil es wurde ja
Für Mittwoch ein Konzept versprochen, wo wir auch langfristig planungssicherheit erhalten und wo wir den wissen, was in etwa
auf uns äh zukommt und ja, was kommt denn jetzt auf uns zu an Maßnahmen und an verstärkten Maßnahmen.
Tja, da gibt's ja äh eine ein äh gibt's fünf äh Slides quasi bei der Bundesregierung, die halt äh,
wesentlichen auf die fünf großen Punkte eingehen aus der Perspektive zumindest, das es fängt an mit den Kontaktbeschränkungen.
Kontaktbeschränkung, Kontakte reduzieren äh ist hier zusammengefasst mit strengere Kontaktbeschränkungen, private Treffen sind auf den,
und einen weiteren Haushalt maximal fünf Personen zusätzlich Kinder bis vierzehn Jahren begrenzt,
Na ja ähm ja.
Weil das nicht bei uns bisher sowieso schon so.
Ja und das ist halt das Ding. Äh your milage may very, also je nach Bundesland wird es dann irgendwie aufgelockert oder äh sogar noch verschärft. So.
Mhm. Also da sozusagen so ein bisschen eine eine Ministellschraube die Anzahl der der Personen, okay, die sich die sich treffen dürfen. Ja, mhm.
Ja gut, aber Haushalte dürfen sich treffen. Bang, so.
Mhm. Wir.
Okay. Hurra.
Ich meine mit wie viel Haushalten triffst du dich denn so binnen einer Woche sowieso äh in der Regel, ja? Also derzeit bestimmt nicht mit so vielen. Jetzt auf jeden Fall einer erlaubt, hätte man halt auch einfach beschränken können. Egal.
Dann steht hier noch dringender Appell, nicht notwendige Kontakte und nicht zwingend erforderliche Reisen vermeiden. Na ja.
OK das ist keine Maßnahme, das.
Es ist alles keine Maßnahme. Und ähm aufgrund des Beschlusses vom achtundzwanzigsten Oktober geschlossene Betriebe und Einrichtungen bleiben weiterhin geschlossen, also Cafés, Knappen und so
Restaurants, Übernachtungsangebote sind weiterhin nur für notwendige nicht touristische Zwecke erlaub,
laufen ja manche äh Länder jetzt auch schon wieder Sturm und wollen das irgendwie so nicht haben. Also Berlin
ne, will,
wobei die Argumentation an der Stelle auch durchaus nachvollziehbar war, ne? Also dieses na ja, äh wir wollen jetzt nicht, dass die Leute sich so sehr zu äh vermischen, aber vielleicht ist so Weihnachten dann doch nicht zu
verhindern, wollen wir noch den Leuten zumindest die Gelegenheit geben, dann im Hotel zu übernachten, weißt du.
Ja gut und danach, was machen die dann? Dann dann kommt die Weihnachtsgans im Garten äh auf den Tisch irgendwie, glaubt ja auch keiner, ne? Also äh,
es es leidet, leidet wie so vieles immer so ein bisschen unter den den Realitäten.
Und.
Soll ich das mal durchgehen? Al.
Ja, ja, ja, lass uns das mal äh durchgehen, genau, also mit anderen Worten äh sagen diese.
Maßnahmen ja eigentlich Verlängerung, also keine Verschärfung. Das heißt, die Auswirkungen dieser Maßnahmen äh äh hier äh die da ausgeführt sind, deren Wirkung ist jetzt im aktuellen Erb schon enthalten.
Dann geht's weiter hier einkaufen und Geschäfte, großen Einzelhandel bleiben geöffnet, also auch Shopping-Malls und so weiter. Maskenpflicht wird erweitert und gilt künftig auch vor Einzelhandelsgeschäften und auf Parkplätzen.
Mhm. Ja.
Ja gut, äh was auch immer das jetzt bringen soll äh,
mir eh nicht vorstellen, dass das einen großen sozialen Druck geben wird in in diesen Dingen. Ich meine, da steht man halt draußen.
Auch so 'ne, ich sag mal, Mikrostellschraube, die vielleicht äh vielleicht tatsächlich ein paar Situationen verhindert, falls sich da irgendwie größere Trauben bilden, äh, oder so, dass man.
Ja, dass die Leute dann quasi äh die Maske schon im Auto aufsetzen, bevor sie aussteigen.
Ja im Idealfall. Strengere Zugangsbeschränkung ab achthunderteins Quadratmeter Verkaufsfläche,
Ganz wichtig, der eine Quadratmeter äh ein Kunde pro zwanzig Quadratmeter, bei kleineren Geschäften, ein Kunde, zehn Quadratmeter.
Ja, weil genauer gesagt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist es so,
dass auf die ersten achthundert Quadratmeter kannst du dann,
ein Kunden pro zehn Quadratmeter und alles was über achthundert Quadratmeter ist kannst du dann nur pro zwanzig Quadratmeter einkunden äh zusätzlich reinlassen. So ist das.
Das wäre eigentlich auch die einzig sinnvolle Lösung, weil sonst weißt du, ein Quadratmeter mehr und auf einmal kannst du doppelt so viele Leute rein äh lassen. Das wird ja auch nicht funktionieren.
Ja, nein, nein, nein, nein. Deswegen ist es so gedacht, dass es hier ein bisschen verkürzt. Dargestell.
Ja, das ist auch sehr sinnvoll, wenn Maßnahmen auf der Seite der Bundesregierung verkürzt dargestellt werden, damit sie dann auch äh alle auf gar keinen Fall richtig interpretieren,
Äh Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden aufgerufen, Weihnachtseinkäufe möglichst auch unter der Woche zu tätigen.
Okay.
Das wirkt alles echt verzweifelt.
Ja.
Okay, auch ein Appell, okay. Also, aber immerhin diese strengeren Zugangsbeschränkungen, also ich ist zumindest ein kleiner äh Punkt, insbesondere Shopping. Ich glaube, das zielt vor allem auch auf Shopping-Malls.
Wo man vermeiden will, dass es dazu Gedränge kommt und ich fand die sagen,
ein Kunde pro zehn Quadratmeter ist ich sage mal alle drei mal drei Meter ist sozusagen ein
ein Kunde und ähm ich fand's manchmal beim Einkaufen jetzt schon doch eigentlich,
unangenehm voll. Also die Zahl der.
Was machst du denn jetzt in dieser Shopping-Mall? So, da hast du kleine Läden und große Läden.
So. Wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, jeder Laden für sich.
So in den kleinen Laden dürfen dann halt äh mehr Leute rein und in den Großen dürfen dann weniger rein, ab einer bestimmten Quadratmeterfläche, wenn das richtig äh okay, das also, aber das heißt, du musst dann pro Laden.
Eine.
Teilnehmeranzahl quasi feststellen, das heißt, jeder Laden muss selber messen, wie viele sind denn jetzt eigentlich drin und und nicht. Also bräuchtest du das so eigentlich in der Shoppingwall? Vor jedem Laden jemanden, der reinlässt.
Und zählt.
Was natürlich irgendwie ein irre Aufwand ist. Die Leute, die nicht reinkommen.
Die stehen dann aber in der Shopping-Wall quasi vor jedem Laden in der Schlange.
Ja, ich glaube, ja, das kann so auch nicht irgendwie sinnvoll sein. Also ich bin gespannt, wie sich das.
Entwickeln wird, aber äh ja in Berlin zumindest war es so, dass seit die.
Kneipen und Restaurants zu sind, die Leute dann äh ja shoppen gehen im Moment tagsüber und dann.
Irgendwie ihren Kaffee äh dann äh sich da to go äh ähm an irgendwelchen Ständen holen und dann ja.
Das als so ein bisschen zur Kompensation äh shoppen und Kaffee trin,
im Einzelhandel. Ja also.
Wird vermutlich ein bisschen auch helfen
so die Zahlen vielleicht nicht ganz so stark ansteigen zu lassen, also da können wir vielleicht auch, weiß nicht, ein halbes Prozent, ein Prozent oder so an Re gewinnen.
Und sicherlich nicht mehr als fünf Prozent.
Maßnahmen nochmal vorstellen, damit wir das also in einem Flow haben hier. Maskenpflicht, in geschlossenen Räumen, die öffentlich oder mit Besuchs,
und Kundenverkehr zugänglich sind, sowie im ÖPNV. Ja okay, gut, ich dachte, das wäre schon die ganze Zeit so. An innerstädtischen Orten mit Publikumsverkehr, Festlegung erfolgt durch örtliche Behörden.
Also draußen, ja.
Mhm. Ja, draußen.
Ja, das ist dann so dieses in dieser Straße werden dann wieder die Radfahrer angehalten oder was.
Genau.
Äh da habe ich auch so ein bisschen, also es ist einfach, man man verschiebt irgendwie die Maßnahmen an so an so einen Orten, wo sie eigentlich wenig bringen, ja?
Einfach so to make a point und damit man irgendwo was gemacht hat, aber bloß nicht da, wo es jetzt für dich sinnvoll wäre. Vor Einzelhandelsgeschäften und auf Parkplätzen hatten wir schon in Arbeits- und Betriebsstätten nicht jedoch am eigenen Platz, wenn der Mindestabstand sicher eingehalten werden kann.
Super.
Warum nicht am eigenen Platz? Das ist doch einfach.
Eigentlich müsste äh sozusagen eigentlich, wenn zwei Leute in einem Büro äh zusammenarbeiten. Vielleicht kann es ja noch zwei Leute in einem, in einem großen Büro, äh wo genüg,
gelüftet wird, würde ich sagen, hm, aber äh alles andere eigentlich äh sollte man,
Ja, maximal zwei Leute in dem Büro. Eigentlich am besten alle ins Homeoffice schicken, alle ins Homeoffice, die wenn nur irgend möglich.
Genau und der Rest muss einfach Basten tragen für dich. So. Maskenkontrollen im Bahnverkehr werden weiter verstärkt. Na schön.
Mhm. Ja, ja, ja. Also auch hier sehe ich jetzt keinen mal nennenswerten Regewinn äh bei diesen Maßnahmen vielleicht auch einen Prozent oder zwei oder wenn überhaupt.
Schulen und Kitas sollen geöffnet bleiben, erweiterte Maskenpflicht regional bei sieben Tage Institut deutlich über fünfzig. Hä?
Was ist? Deutlich oder fünfzig ist, fünfundfünfzig, deutlich über fünfzig, einundfünfzig, achtundsiebzig? Einhundertdreiundzwanzig, was ist deutlich über fünfzig.
Und dann ab Klasse sieben optional für Grundschulen und in Klassen fünf und sechs. Optional? Warum.
Mal heißt vermutlich keine option äh also das eine, dass die Pflicht optional eingeführt werden kann von einzelnen Ländern für Klassen fünf und sechs.
Wie viel, wie viel komplizierter kann man's denn noch machen? Und vor allem, warum nicht? Warum sie verstehen nicht, warum man einem in der fünften Klasse nicht einfach eine Massenpflicht einführen kann.
Ja
Ehrlich gesagt verstehe ich das auch für die die Klassen dadrunter nicht. Okay. Erstlässler, Zweitlässler, dann lasse ich noch irgendwie ein bisschen mit mir äh reden. Aber Kinder in der fünften Klasse, ich bitte dich. Also das funktioniert.
Das ist dann halt einfach so und dann fertig. So wird einfach das nur weiter mit in die Richtung mit reingegeben,
So, dann bei besonders hohen Infektionszahlen Institanzgröße zweihundert, hier wird zumindest mal definiert, was hoch ist
ne. Ab Klasse acht weitere Maßnahmen, Hybridwechselunterricht, das ist ja auch etwas, wo so ein bisschen alle zum Jagen getragen werden mussten, dass die Schulen dann halt nicht unbedingt äh dazu gezwungen wird,
Hybrid heißt halt Klassenaufteilung und äh ne, Rübenrot und und vor Ort äh im Wechselunterricht.
Das sind generell gute Nachrichten äh für eine Klasse, denke ich mal. Also ist natürlich Aufwand, klar ist mir schon klar, ist ja auch betroffen, aber so verringert man dann eben einfach den Einzugskreis, ne?
Und ich höre das ja auch aus den äh Schulen, wo ich meine Kinder habe so, ja, ja, jetzt hat's den Lehrer erwischt, hat's den Lehrer erwischt und.
Sind irgendwelche Schüler in der Parallelklasse betroffen.
Es geht darum, ist einfach so. Schülerverkehr entzerren zum Beispiel mit gestaffelten Unterrichtsbeginn, das wird hier zumindest in Berlin schon gemacht.
Sodass man jeden Tag sich immer wieder überlegen muss, wann geht's denn heute eigentlich in die Schule los? Ähm einheitliche Kontrollstrategie, verstärkter Einsatz von antigen Schnelltests, Hurra, verstärkter Einsatz von Antigenschnelltest, an Schulen und Kitas,
nichts von gehört, außer diesen.
Von uns hier schon besprochenen einzelnen Schulen, wo das sozusagen gezielt gemacht wird, also wo welche prototypischen.
Maßnahmen da ergriffen werden, so Pilotprojekte, aber nicht im Allgemeinen. So letzter Punkt, Weihnachten und Silvester.
Lockerung von Weihnachten bis neue Jahr, dreiundzwanzigster zwölfter bis erster erster.
Treffen im Endes engsten Familien oder Freundeskreis, maximal zehn Personen zuzüglich Kinder bis vierzehn Jahren sind möglich. Okay.
Also Weihnachten soll stattfinden. Vollzone Weihnachtsferien bundesweit ab neunzehnten zwölften.
Ja gut äh klingt auch erstmal total äh toll für Leute, die nicht wissen, wann die Ferien anfangen, also Leute ohne Kinder.
Der der neunzehnte zwölfte ist ähm ein Samstag.
Und normalerweise wäre in den meisten Ländern der Montag der einundzwanzigste noch ein Schultag gewesen. Wo ich mich sowieso frage, wer.
Warum, weshalb, wieso? Also das ist einfach mal ganz abgesehen von der Panemie. Was soll der Quatsch.
Wenn da nur nur noch ein Montag in Frage kommt vor den Weihnachtsferien, dann,
doch den Scheiß Montag da noch mit da rein, damit er noch ein Wochenende äh mehr Ferien ist. An dem Tag machen die Kinder eh nicht mehr, als da irgendwie kurz nochmal zwei, drei Stunden rumzusitzen und es war's,
Ja, also es ist eh absurd. Sprich diese Maßnahme verlängert jetzt diese Ferien um drei Tage.
Und ja gut meinetwegen, aber für so eine Weihnachtsquarantäne reicht das halt auch nicht aus. Hätte man jetzt gesagt wir packen noch eine ganze Woche dazu.
Ja, also wir hätten jetzt äh ab dem zwölften Dezember einfach schon zugemacht. Dann wäre das eine Ansage gewesen.
Also da da kann man dann auch mit arbeiten, ja?
Ja, ich weiß, wenn die Schulen zu sind und Leute, die arbeiten und Betreuungsproblemen und ich weiß, das ist auch alles schwierig, ja. Man hätte es ja zumindest machen können für äh ältere Semester, also für Klassen ab
was weiß ich, ab äh ab der siebten Klasse oder so, äh wo einfach oder achte Klasse, wo einfach eine gewisse Eigenständigkeit äh vorherrscht bei den Kids, wo man jetzt nicht,
unbedingt noch permanent Betreuung für die Kinder braucht, wo es auch mal okay ist, wenn die dann mal zu Hause sind. Aber dann hätten die zumindest die Möglichkeit gehabt, sich einfach eine Woche lang aus allem rauszuhalten.
Zwei Wochen im Prinzip für Weihnachten. Na ja, findet aber nicht statt.
Ja, so mit anderen Worten, Schulen sollen aufbleiben, steht da auch höchst, hat höchste Priorität, dass die Schulen aufbleiben, ja?
Nachvollziehbar, aber dazu.
Muss man halt die Infektionszahlen niedrig halten und da kann man noch so viel priorisieren, wenn die Zahlen hochgehen äh so ähm muss man was tun. So, da nützt auch die Priorität dann nix mehr.
Ja und das wäre jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so das große Problem gewesen, wenn man jetzt der Schule eine Woche entzieht, dann kann man die dann halt bei den Sommerferien auch abziehen.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, also wir können es ich kann mir auch eine Welt vorstellen in der die Sommerferien vier Wochen lang sind.
Dieses Jahr mal, so. Und dafür nimmt man halt eine Woche oder zwei Wochen,
in potenzielle Logdown Situationen noch mit rein, weil das ist jetzt sowieso nicht der letzte. Könnt ihr euch jetzt schon mal drauf einstellen. Also das die nächste Welle äh kommt bestimmt.
Um das hier noch kurz zu Ende zu erzielen, Regelungen zum Jahreswechsel, Empfehlung auf privates Silvesterfeuerwerk zu verzichten auf belebten Straßen und Plätzen ist es untersagt.
Toll, als ob das so das Primärproblem wäre, das Hauptproblem ist, dass die Leute sich halt ihre Hände wegballern, dann die Krankenhäuser rotieren und die haben gerade wirklich was Besseres zu tun.
Und für Berlin ist es glaube ich, ist, glaube ich, komplett äh privates Feuerwerk, glaube ich, verboten worden, wenn ich mich, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Aha, bist du sicher? Habe ich jetzt noch nichts von gehört? Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Okay. Ähm ja.
Kontaktreduzierung bei Gottesdiensten, religiöse Großveranstaltungen und jetzt wäre mein Lieblingswort vermeiden. Weihnachten und Silvester, Grußveranstaltungen, religiöse Großveranstaltungen vermeiden. Mhm.
Also einmal wollten keine Einschränkungen für Gottesdienste oder äh Kirchen oder es auch nur einen Appell. Also Kirchen bleiben auch auf.
Genau, letzter Punkt ist auch nochmal ein Appell, der hier auch explizit Appell heißt, Appell an Arbeitgeberinnen und Arbeitgebermöglichkeit von Betriebsferien oder großzügigen Homeoffice-Lösungen prüfen.
Ähm ich finde einerseits kann man sagen ja super Appell an die Eigenverantwortung der Bürger,
äh kann man jetzt erstmal nichts gegen sagen, außer ähm,
dass das natürlich Wettbewerbsverzerrend bewirkt, wenn es bei einem Appell bleibt,
Das heißt, äh damit bringt man, also wenn man's, wenn man Sachen bei einem Appell beläst, führt es dazu, dass Arbeitgeber, die.
Erweiterten oder darüber hinausgehenden Gesundheitsschutz
ich sag mal anbieten oder mehr Betriebsferien machen
eigentlich schlechter gestellt sind als diejenigen, äh die dann einfach auf Teufel kommen raus, äh ja, die Leute arbeiten lassen. Klar, bei denen kommt dann wahrscheinlich noch, dass dass das dicke Ende, aber
Appelle äh sage ich mal äh ja halte ich, halte ich für problematisch an vielen Stellen. Entweder es gibt eine Regelung, dann ist das auch für alle gleich,
so wie das, wie das auszusehen hat, äh oder ja, Appell äh geschenkt. Ähm zumal.
Tatsächlich die meisten Betriebe äh auch wesentlich besser als hier, wenn Gesundheitsämter, die öffentliche Hand, weil ich es geschafft haben, schon Infektionen zu vermeiden, also zumindest bei den Betrieben.
Nicht bei allen, aber bei vielen Betrieben, die ich so kenne, so hat man da ja ähm.
Doch jede Menge Maßnahmen mit äh es dürfen sich nur so und so viele Leute überhaupt äh ähm,
aufhalten und es muss sich jeder eintragen, auch jeder Besucher und so Führung von Besucherlisten und Maskenpflicht äh,
in den weiten äh Teilen und so, das ist bereits so in ganz, ganz vielen Unternehmen. So, insofern und äh,
Homeoffice äh weiß ich auch, äh ist jetzt auch in vielen Unternehmen wieder hochgefahren äh worden. So, also da das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auch schon im aktuellen Erbe enthalten. Äh ist wahrscheinlich nicht mehr nicht mehr wirklich viel zu holen.
Ähm eine interessante äh Sache, dann äh äh war noch okay. Äh,
Ja, was passiert denn jetzt, wenn die Zahlen nach oben gehen? Und da hat man dann zu mir gesagt, okay, äh es gibt jetzt diese Institz von zweihundert Neuinfektionen pro,
hunderttausend Einwohner und die Fuseminfektionsgeschehen, also was sie damit meinen, ist.
Ausgenommen ist, wenn jetzt durch Heime oder ja wenn es wenn es so Massenausbrüche,
in einem eingrenzbaren Umfeld gegeben hat, dann soll das halt auch nicht zählen, was man verstehen kann, aber äh ob das überhaupt ermittelbar ist, äh jetzt im Moment äh überhaupt alle größeren Cluster
Egal. Zweihundert Neuinfektionen pro hunderttausend Einwohner sollen,
diese Maßnahmen nochmals erweitert werden, um kurzfristig eine deutliche Absenkung der Infektionszahlen zu erreichen. Also.
Ich lese oder verstehe das so, dass man gesagt hat, okay, bei über zweihundert,
halten wir uns noch beliebige andere Maßnahmen offen, die wir hier jetzt äh euch aber nicht mitteilen wollen, weil äh ja, wollen euch jetzt nicht,
mehr verunsichern äh als äh ohnehin nötig. Das heißt auch Schulschließungen.
Ja, erweiterte Ausgangssperren und Betriebsschließungen sind jetzt nicht vom Tisch, werden aber hier nicht explizit äh genannt. Und ähm,
wenn wir jetzt mal gucken ähm so vielleicht.
Zweihundert Neuinfektionen, wie für Landkreise betrifften das jetzt eigentlich.
Wo man verschärfen müsste.
Sagen knapp an die nicht ganz hundert äh Landkreise, nur achtzig, neunzig Landkreise liegen im Moment über zweihundert bei der äh bei der Institanz,
kann, können halt auch schärfere Maßnahmen kommen, aber äh was wissen wir nicht. Mit anderen Worten wir sind jetzt nicht wirklich schlauer, äh was,
eigentlich auf uns zukommt. So, das Einzige, was wir wissen, ist auf gar keinen Fall sind irgendwie Lockerungen zu erwarten, wobei auch dort.
Es die Möglichkeit gibt, wenn für Landkreise, die unter fünfzig sind, ähm die.
Können dann wiederum auch abweichen und können dann weniger strenge Maßnahmen verhängen.
Aber das wird doch alles nur wieder dazu führen, dass wir wieder so ein Wildwuchs haben. Und ich meine, wir hatten ja jetzt hier schon letzte Mal ein paar Mal schon über diese schönen einfachen Matrixen gesprochen und es gibt einfach ein Level und der gilt einfach fürs ganze Land und fettig. Ich meine, das ist einfach
so wird es nix. Also ich habe relativ wenig Hoffnung,
dass wir hier im Januar über irgendeine annennenswert andere Situation berichten werden als derzeit,
jetzt so ein bisschen, wie ich's sehe. Ich lasse mich da auch ganz gerne überraschen. Aber ähm ich habe da ehrlich gesagt so meine Zweifel.
Mein meine Erwartungshaltung wäre jetzt alles bleibt gleich oder wird schlimmer. Nach Weihnachten wird's dann nochmal schlimmer.
Und ähm dann wird spätestens Ende Januar, wenn die Todeszahlen halt irgendwo wieder gestiegen sind, für was weiß ich, vielleicht bei sechs, siebenhundert Leuten, die pro Tag sterben äh sind,
ist das Geschrei dann wieder groß und dann müssen sie doch noch einen richtigen Lokdown machen. Der dann nochmal länger dauern wird, ja? Und dann,
geht das Ding einfach bis Ende Februar. So und wenn wir Glück haben, wird's dann ab März wieder besser.
So, das ist der, ich sag mal der wahrscheinlichste Verlauf, ja? Also es Februar oder März, wenn die Dinge gut laufen.
Alles so läuft wie ja in den in den nächsten Wochen. Ach so sind übrigens äh.
Ja nicht achtzehn Landkreise, die gerade unter fünfzig äh sind von von vierhundert so die.
Ja, aber was heißt schon fünfzig? Meine fünfzig ist das, wovor äh wo vor Monat dann groß äh rumgeschrien wurde. Oh Gott, Berlin, die infizierte Zone, ja äh Institanz,
fünfzig und darf man sich mit Berlinern darf man mit Berlinern überhaupt noch ein Telefongespräch äh führen oder die
hinter mir isoliert ein Hotelzimmer halten und jetzt so, ja, fünfzig wäre ja mal ganz geil wieder so. Da können wir ja schon wieder richtig Party machen.
Das das einfach die Verhältnisse sind einfach vollkommen.
Aus dem aus dem Ruder geraten. Es gibt gar keinen Bezug mehr zu diesen Zahlen. Nicht nur, weil man den Zahlen halt selber jetzt insofern nicht glauben darf, als das schon ihre Berechnung problematisch ist, sondern dass einfach wir überhaupt gar nicht mehr wissen, wo wollen wir denn überhaupt hin,
Was ist denn ein Zustand, äh den wir haben wollen? Und äh ich fände ja mal so eine Ansage wie wir wollen einen R von null Komma sieben.
Bevor wir den nicht erreicht haben, wird einfach jede Woche weiter verschärft. So.
Mit so einem Plan. Gucke mal, wenn wir, wenn wir nicht auf R null Komma sieben kommen, dann in zwei Wochen das, in drei Wochen das, in vier Wochen das.
Wir wissen alle, was auf einen zukommt und dann wissen auch alle schon vorher, dass dass es auf einen zukommt und dann können auch alle mithelfen, das entsprechend zu machen,
Aber derzeit ist es so, ja, wir machen mal irgendwas und dann gucken wir mal, ach so, wir haben so null Komma neun, das klingt ja ganz gut. Es hilft uns halt auch nicht weiter, wenn wir in der Zwischenzeit irgendwie äh wieder,
gegangen sind.
Ja, null Komma neun wäre ja schon mal äh wäre ja schon mal ein Erfolg äh so und wenn wir äh null Komma neun aufrechterhalten äh würden, dann äh äh kämen wir,
tatsächlich irgendwann vielleicht auch in die Zone ähm.
Dass die Gesundheitsämter äh auch wieder ein bisschen mehr durch Tracking und Tracing und Isolation nennenswert einwirken können auf das Infektionsgeschehen, aber das ist ja,
im Moment faktisch nicht der Fall.
Machen wir uns nichts vor, das ist blindflug. Also es ist einfach äh derzeit hat einfach keiner mehr den Überblick und äh das Infektionsgeschehen ist im Prinzip außer Kontrolle.
Ich meine wir haben angeblich gleichbleibende Zahlen, aber auf dem Level, den wir nicht haben wollen und das geht einfach alles gar nicht und
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen angefressen, dass das nicht mehr Mut gezeigt wird, weil wir wissen ja alle, was das bedeutet. Das bedeutet, dass wir es dann später trotzdem machen müssen und es noch länger dauert,
dass es alles, was man daraus ziehen kann.
Kommen wir jetzt mal zu den Impfstoffen. Ähm, das wird ja eigentlich das spannende Thema der nächsten Monate bleiben, hoffe ich zumindest.
Es gab jetzt einen dritten, neuen Impfstoff, der äh verkündet wurde, dass äh hier doch äh Erfolge erzielt wurden,
Aber da lohnt es sich nochmal genauer hinzuschauen. Worum geht es? Es geht um einen Impfstoff, der an der Ochsford Universität.
Entwickelt wurde.
Der galt auch schon länger als so ein Kandidat äh irgendwann nochmal erfolgreich zu sein. Das ist ein
Impfstoff, der jetzt auf eine klassische Methode hergestellt wurde. Wir erinnern uns, moderner und der Biontech-Impfstoff. Das sind,
Stoffe auf Basis dieser neuen MRNA-Methode, wo quasi mit
Dieser Botenstoff RNA in die Zelle direkt der Bauauftrag für das Bauen, für das Bauen, für das Produzieren dieses äh Proteins, an denen man den Corona Virus erkennt
geschickt wurde,
abbaut und man hatte zwar bisher noch keine Erfolge mit dieser Technik, das ist alles ganz neu, aber man ist da sehr zuversichtlich und das haben ja auch die Ergebnisse soweit erstmal bestätigt.
Hier ähm,
ist das Ganze auf Basis von Dinovieren, was halt äh so im Affen vorkommende Viren sind, die werden dann halt entsprechend modifiziert. Das ist eine abgehangene Methode und äh man hat halt hier versucht, eben dann auch auf.
Über diesen Trägerstoff ähm den Bauauftrag für dieses Corona Virus Protein äh in den Körper zu schicken und das scheint auch funktioniert zu haben. Hier wurde jetzt,
Zwischenergebnis auch wieder veröffentlicht von der derzeitigen Phase drei, also der letzten Phase, in der die Wirksamkeit eines Impfstoffs dann im breiten Feld geprüft wird,
Zwischenergebnis wurde veröffentlicht und da hieß es erstmal siebzig Prozent Wirksamkeit.
Da kann man dann sagen so, aha, na ja, nur siebzig Prozent, die anderen hatten aber neunzig oder fünfundneunzig. Ja.
Da scheint aber so ein bisschen was Komisches passiert zu sein. Zunächst einmal gab's so zwei Kohorten, die man trennen muss. Und in der einen Kohorte.
Wo zwei Dosierungen äh dieses Impfstoffs den Leuten gegeben wurde, gingen im Vergleich zur Kontrollgruppe äh nur bei sechzig, zweiundsechzig Prozent der Leuten, äh kam es dann eben nicht zu einer.
Ähm Infekt äh zu einer zum Ausbruch der Krankheit, also oder
in dem Fall sogar auch tatsächlich nicht zu einer Infektion, weil das ist jetzt hier was Besonderes. Hier wurden dann eben auch die Leute äh regelmäßig getestet, so dass man eben auch die asymptomatischen Erkrankungen ähm.
Sehen konnte, also man hat halt gesehen, aha, Leute haben sich nicht infiziert oder haben sich infiziert, sind aber a symptomatisch und von daher ist es schon mal äh ein interessanterer Ansatz, das wurde jetzt bei diesen MRNA Sachen soweit ich weiß, nicht gemacht,
Das habe ich davon noch nix gelesen. Nun gab es aber noch eine zweite Gehorte, die allerdings nicht geplant war,
sondern es hatte sich da wohl um einen Verpackungsfehler gehandelt. Die haben einfach bestimmte Proben.
Bestimmte Impfstoffdosierung an Leute in den falschen Dosierungen rausgegeben. Ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, was da jetzt,
falsch gelaufen ist. Es war
Verpackungsproblem die Rede, also es ist vielleicht nur die Hälfte eingepackt worden oder so. Auf jeden Fall führte das dazu, dass die Leute, die geimpft wurden, in der ersten
Impfungen. Es waren auch hier wie bei den anderen zwei Impfungen, im Abstand von paar Wochen. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viel Wochen äh vorgenommen worden,
Und die Dosierung bei der ersten Impfung lag nur bei der Hälfte dessen, was sie eigentlich verabreichen wollen.
Die zweite war dann eben mit der höheren Dosierung. Das hatte wiederum zur Folge, dass hier neunzig Prozent.
Aller geimpften, geschützt wurden.
Und jetzt fragen sich alle äh erstmal, was ist hier eigentlich mit der Verpackungsproblem irgendwie? Was ist denn da schiefgelaufen, weil das ist natürlich wirklich ähm.
Also bei der Nummer möchte man keine Fehler machen, aber offensichtlich wurde ja ein Fehler gemacht. Und dann hat er eben auch noch zur Folge
offenbar im in dieser Phase drei und ich kann jetzt nicht genau sagen, wie viele Leute das konkret betroffen hat. Das war, glaube ich, der kleinere Teil,
da gab's halt bessere Ergebnisse und jetzt wurde auch schon angekündigt, sie wollen dann eben diese
drei noch intensivieren und dann explizit nochmal mit niedrig Hochdosierungskombination testen. Kann gut sein, dass man hier,
auf neuen Spin gekommen ist, auf so einen neuen, auf eine neue Idee gekommen ist, die man so vorher gar nicht ausprobiert hat, weil das hatte sozusagen keiner.
Vermutet, es war keine Strategie, dass man sagt so, ah, mal gucken, wenn wir erstmal weniger gibt und dann dann mehr, vielleicht wirkt das ja besser.
Bei denen die geimpft wurden, gab es keine schweren Fälle, dass es auch interessant.
Und insgesamt wurden wohl so vierundzwanzig Tests äh durchgeführt und zwar so.
Vierundzwanzigtausend.
Vierundzwanzigtausend und das in äh UK, Brasilien und Südafrika.
Wenn dieser Impfstoff sich jetzt hier weiter bewährt und eben
Nach Abschluss dieser Phase drei und insbesondere nach Abschluss dieser verlängerten Phase drei mit diesen äh mit diesem
äh asymmetrisch äh also asymmetrischen Dosierung. Wenn das jetzt alles positiv verläuft und tatsächlich hier auch eine Zulassung erfolgt,
Ist es insofern eine interessante Ergänzung zu den MRNA-Impfstoffen, weil erstens dieser Impfstoff,
kann ist also muss nicht so kalt gelagert werden
Ja, wir erinnern uns, der Björn Tisch im Stoff will ja bei minus siebzig Grad gelagert werden, der von moderner, da hieß es dann minus zwanzig. Hier reicht Kühlschrank, zwei bis acht Grad. Also muss noch nicht mal gefroren sein,
Und das äh entspricht, ich meine, das ist, wie ich schon sagte, äh Impfstoffe auf Basis der Modifikation dieser Adinoviren,
Viktorimpfstoffe, die brauchen eben
die kennt man halt schon lange und da braucht man einfach diese Kühlung nicht. Und das wäre natürlich dann für eine Verteilung in Ländern, wo man jetzt nicht so eine permanente Kühlkette so ohne Weiteres ähm sicherstellen kann, mit besonders niedrigen Temperaturen großer Vorteil.
Außerdem,
läuft die Produktion von diesem Impfstoff bereits in zehn Ländern, unter anderem wohl auch in Indien, wo extrem große Kapazitäten vorhanden sind, um äh Impfstoffe auf dieser
Technologiebasis durchzuführen, sodass dann eben auch wirklich große Mengen produziert werden kann. Hier ist also schon,
wird schon von drei Milliarden Dosierungen geredet, die geplant sind. So und das ist natürlich dann auch ähm.
Sehr schön, weil das bedeutet, dass man eben wirklich, wirklich, wirklich viele Leute erreichen kann. Ja, das ist sozusagen das, was man jetzt hier.
Ähm sieht, besonders freut sich über diesen Impfstoff, die äh etwas Skandal geplagte UK-Regierung.
So begeistert von ihrem eigenen Impfstoff ist, weil es ja Ochsford, Universität und überhaupt und kommt aus Großbritannien und so und wenn äh Großbritannien gerade irgendwas gut gebrauchen kann, dann sind es gute Nachrichten.
Weil die sind gerade in äh Limited Surply wegen Brexit und so weiter,
Jetzt kam der Gesundheitsminister und wollte doch tatsächlich Astra-Senika, dass die die Produktion Distruption machen von dem Schoff äh
dazu bringen, dass du auch bitte alle Dosierfläschchen, die ausgeliefert werden, einen Union Jack drauf haben. Das ja, das da irgendwie noch klar wird, dass das jetzt sozusagen.
Oh man ja das ist Trump Pesk.
Weil absolut, die kümmern sich wirklich um die wirklich wichtigen Probleme, ne? Ansonsten, was so die anderen Impfstoffe betrifft.
Wird aber an dieser Distribution gearbeitet, also so UPS und auch DHL und andere große Logistikunternehmen, die sind wohl auch schon dabei
jetzt für die MRNA Impfstoffe dafür zu sorgen, dass sie halt in ihrer Verteilungslogi.
Sogenannte Freezer Farms haben, also es ist wirklich solche Tiefkühlschrank
Lager zwischen Lager einrichten, um einen Transport auch dieser anderen Impfstoffe zu garantieren.
Ja
Teilweise existiert sowas auch schon, also es ist nichts Neues, ja? Äh gerade so für die mittleren Temperaturen, also es ist nicht so das erste Mal, dass die Impfstoffe äh.
Durch die Gegend schicken, Grippeimpfstoffe werden seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten im großen, großen, großen Mengen verteilt und auch da ist das äh schon relevant. Nur dass halt unter Umständen jetzt die Anforderungen eben nochmal steigen,
Und daran wird eben auch von den Logistikunternehmen gearbeitet, um das Ganze entsprechend zu verteilen.
Wobei natürlich.
Jetzt mal auch sagen muss, so erfreulich das ist mit den Stoffen und äh ähm es gibt.
Vor allem Hoffnung, dass ja wir äh nächsten Sommer einen äh vielleicht normalen
Sommer erleben äh können, aber für die nächsten eins, zwei, drei Monate
äh wird das auf die Zahlen keinen größeren Einfluss haben, dass das äh Impfen
vielleicht, wenn man, wenn's gelingt, halt die Risikogruppen so achtzig Plus oder fünfundsiebzig plus und Krankenhauspersonal
ähm und andere.
Ja äh Lehrer vielleicht schnell durch äh zu impfen, aber vor allem halt Risikogruppen, dass man damit äh zumindest äh dann äh die Zahl der Toten
nennenswert senken könnte. So ja aber.
Dass das jetzt sozusagen noch in diesem Jahr oder im im Januar oder im Februar gar die Zahlen beeinflusst, halte ich für ausgeschlossen.
Ich auch. Also äh ich denke mal kurzfristig kann es jetzt nur um eine Absicherung,
der absoluten Hochrisikogruppen gehen und des Gesundheitssystems und das wäre ja auch schon mal sehr wünschenswert, also wird das zumindest mal alle, die in medizinischen Berufen arbeiten, äh Krankenhäusern, et cetera, alle Ärzte,
alle einmal durchimpfen, bitteschön. Ja, jetzt bin ich ja voll dafür und dann natürlich eben auch so's äh sich zeigt.
Dass es auch bei ältesten wirkt, dass man eben einfach die.
Schlimmsten betroffenen Gruppen, sprich die Achtzigjährigen, äh, achtzig plus diese ganzen Kroaten und dann langsam nach unten arbeiten, dass man die vorzieht. So, ganz klar.
Ja und dann kann man auch eine hat man auch eine Basis für die weitere Bekämpfung und das ist ja auch schon mal was. Ich bin da relativ optimistisch, muss ich sagen.
Dann gibt es noch eine Nachricht aus äh nochmal aus Ochsford. Da ist man offenbar ganz fleißig am Forschen. Und die äh Leute haben sich mal.
Diese Verbreitung des Corona Virus angeschaut,
der Welt und zwar gar nicht so sehr,
nachdem das alles so richtig ausgebrochen ist, sondern und das,
Klang bei uns glaube ich auch schon ein paar Mal an. Das hatten wir glaube ich schon vor Monaten mal solche Berichte, wo man nicht so genau wusste hm, da ist was gefunden in alten Abwasserproben.
Und das wurde jetzt mal alles so ein bisschen zusammengesucht und zusammen konsolidiert und das ergibt ein interessantes Bild. Also in.
Abgespeicherten Abwasserproben in Spanien, in Brasilien, in Mailand und Turin.
Aus dem Jahr zweitausendneunzehn.
In diesen Proben konnte das uns so terrorisierende Corona Virus Zweifels ohne gefunden werden,
Die spanische Probe ist aus dem März zwanzig neunzehn die brasilianische Probe ist aus dem November zwanzig neunzehn und die italienischen Proben sind aus dem Dezember zwanzig und neunzehn.
Es gibt also relativ klare Indizierung dafür, dass das Virus quasi da war und zwar nicht nur in China.
Also es ist.
Nicht klar, dass dieses Virus aus China kommt, sondern es kann sehr gut sein, dass China der Ort war, wo es zum ersten Ausbruch kam.
Also wo tatsächlich Infektion von Menschen ähm auf eine Art und Weise stattgefunden hat in einer Menge stattgefunden hat, dass es eben auffällig wurde.
Trotzdem ist es irgendwie schon.
Reist und es war offensichtlich schon so ein bisschen in der Welt.
Das klingt natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen komisch, ist es vielleicht auch.
Man versucht sich daraus gerade so ein Reim äh äh zu machen.
Und ähm dass wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe gehen die Theorien so in diese Richtung okay, vielleicht gibt es einfach auch noch.
Distributionswege, die wir so bisher nicht so beachten. Wir nehmen das Ding ja so als,
respiratorischen Virus war und das ist ja so das Hauptproblem die Verbreitung über die Luft
Und das führt dann eben auch zu diesen großen Ausbruchzahlen, aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass das zwangsläufig der einzige Weg ist.
Hier wird halt über eine Verbreitung, über die Kanalisation, öffentliche Toiletten, also Schmierinfektionen und so weiter durchaus nachgedacht.
Also dass das sozusagen so eine so eine Software Minimalverbreiterung gefunden hat. Nicht eben in diesen bedrohlichen Zahlen, wie wir sie jetzt haben.
Und dafür würde ja auch sprechen, da haben wir das letzte Mal glaube ich auch schon drüber gesprochen, dass man eben sieht so, ja das Virus, das kann ganz gut überleben, in kalten und in feuchten Regionen.
Ja,
Stichwort Fledermaus höhlen, ja oder eben auch Stichwort Kanalisation. Das äh äh sind halt im Prinzip auch so die modernen Fledermaushöhlen. Also das ist sozusagen durchaus möglich, dass sich das Virus hier auch lange hält,
Und äh das ist ja auch so ein bisschen die Basis, äh dass eben.
Man auch glaubt so, ja, das könnte auch erklären, warum die Ausbrüche in diesen fleischverarbeitenden Betrieben so,
war, weil man sich alle, ehrlich gesagt, das so aus der.
So wie die Zahlen sich dargestellt hat,
wie die Situation in diesem fleischverarbeitenden Betrieben sind so allein über Atemwegsübertragung so auch nicht hat erklären kann warum die Ausbrüche da so stark waren
dass eben hier aber eben die kalten Temperaturen unter Umständen noch dazu beigetragen haben,
ähm dass die Verbreitung eben auch jenseits von Atemwegen irgendwie noch relevant war. Ja, also es ist ein bisschen,
schwierig, ich hab's jetzt im Detail mir nicht die ganzen Papers durchgelesen, sondern so diese Berichte dadrüber
weil letzten Endes ja okay, dann schwimmen die Viren rum, halten sich lange, aber wie vervielfältigen sie sich, also sie müssen ja dann doch irgendwie durch irgendein Organismus äh gehen, um sich äh dann entsprechend zu verbreiten.
Und ähm man hat halt einfach äh glaube ich.
Weiß man einfach auch noch nicht so richtig viel davon. Es wurde dann auch noch von so einem anderen Fall berichtet. Ich will das jetzt nicht mehr so breit treten, weil ich hab
habe dann die Berichterstattung mir mal genauer angeschaut und es machte für mich irgendwie auch alles,
in der in der Schilderung so richtig keine ähm kein keinen Sinn, aber es gibt so aus dem Februar so Berichte, dass es dann äh auf einmal einen Ausbruch gab auf so einem Kreuzfahrtschiff.
Dass unten im Bereich,
Antarktis Südgeorgien unterwegs war. Weiß nicht, ob das schon mal was von Süd.
Gehört hast, wo das so ist, kennst wahrscheinlich die Falkline Inseln.
Südgeorgien ist nochmal nochmal weiter weg und nochmal näher dran an der Antarktis. Das ist so der letzte,
Der letzte Ort vor der Antarktis ähm wo es irgendwie menschliche Siedlungen gibt, die aber nicht dauerhaft bewohnt ist.
Nur so im Sommer da mal so ein paar Leute findet.
Gab es da nicht auch im Zusammenhang äh äh mit dem Falklandkrieg wurden die nicht auch dann kurz besetzt und dann wieder zurückerobert oder so.
Südgeorgien.
Weiß ich nicht. Also soweit ich das sehe ist Südgeorgien mehr nur so ein Expeditionssprungbrett und das äh da hat so ein bisschen touristische Bewegungen, aber da da leben liegt dauerhaft Menschen
ist nicht wirklich ein Ort. Das gehört alles irgendwie der Krone und äh ist ja auch egal. Auf jeden Fall gab's da wohl so eine eine ähm,
Kreuzfahrt, die da unterwegs war und da gab's dann halt auch irgendwie ein äh ein Ausbruch.
Der sich aber so richtig nicht erklären lässt, weil die natürlich auch wochenlang unterwegs sind, Südgeorgien ist so mit mit Flugzeugen auch gar nicht,
reichen, da kannst du nur mit dem Schiff äh unterwegs sein und das sind alles ziemliche Distanzen,
kurz gesagt, die These, die jetzt hier im Kontext dieser Berichterstattung noch auf.
Wurde ist, dass es sich unter Umständen über eine Infektion über aufgetautes Essen.
Handeln.
Ja, dass also Viren dann auch in der Lage sind, sich äh quasi bei ganz tiefen Temperaturen in Essen zu halten und dann eben über,
weil's nicht im Mundbereich, ja, nimmst halt quasi den Virus aus diesem aufgetauchten Essen äh auf und äh kannst dich darüber infizieren, ne? Also.
Nichts genaues weiß man nicht ähm auf jeden Fall zeichnet sich hier ab.
Dass wir da noch lange nicht am Ende sind. Bei der Erforschung der Ursprünge und der der Transportwege dieses und anderer Viren.
Ja ich hatte halt auch nochmal geguckt jetzt gerade.
Saß es mit den Schlachthöfen, wie das sind eigentlich mit Schweinen äh aussieht, äh ob die empfänglich sind für irgendwie.
Saß Koff zwei.
Und angeblich ist ihm nicht so so wären viele andere Tiere sehr wohl, also Frettchen oder Flughunde äh Schweine und Hühner angeblich nicht,
also zumindest ja scheinen sie ihn nicht vermehren zu können den Erreger,
Frage ist natürlich auch, ob das äh so bleibt, es auch gehört, dass es ein neues Schweinekorona Virus äh äh gibt, was jetzt äh wohl, ja, also in China sind wohl jetzt irgendwie im Oktober massenhaft,
Schweine an einem Corona-Virus nahmen Satz äh SADS-Kopf äh gestorben,
ja, Spookie. Also ich meine, wir haben da Glück, man stelle sich vor, äh jetzt ähm,
Es werden nicht nur Närze äh die befallen werden, äh könnten, sondern auch Schweine,
und Deutschland müsste seinen gesamten Schweinebestand äh.
Keulen.
Keulen, dass das wäre mal eine äh ja das wäre richtig krass.
Und ich meine aus und sagen vielleicht auch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass es eine Mutation gibt, wenn viel Virus da ist und vielleicht viele infizierte Menschen auch Kontakt mit Schwein haben, wer weiß,
ob's dann nicht doch durch eine Mutation oder so dann sich auch unter Schweinen verbreitet. Ist wahrscheinlich unwahrscheinlich, aber das wäre auch nochmal so ein, so eine Art Supergau.
Jetzt müssen wir aber langsam äh erstens zum Ende kommen und zweitens auch wieder so die positive Grundhaltung äh herauskehren. Sonst äh trennen ja alle nur noch schreiend durch die Straßen, nachdem sie unseren Podcast gehört haben.
Das geht ja nur auch nicht.
Los, jetzt sind wir ganz schnell ganz positiv. Haben wir einen positiven Ausblick, ja haben wir.
Ja, ja, ja. Ähm gut,
immerhin Schnelltestfront ist auf jeden Fall äh so ein, so ein auch noch so ein weiterer Hoffnungsschimmer, äh der es auch,
mindest möglich machen würde, wenn man denn wollte, auch großflächig die gesamte Bevölkerung,
testen, was jetzt leider auch nicht geplant ist. Aber zumindest äh kann man damit auch noch
wiederum ja Altersheime oder andere äh äh Gruppen,
vielleicht besonders absichern.
Zumal jetzt auch die ganzen Schnelltests eigentlich sehr gute Beurteilungen bekommen haben. Also da gab's ja glaube ich die Studie von Drosten und
glaube ich schon erwähnt haben, die generell äh gesagt hat, so ja hier das äh kann alles, das Virus äh bei einer bestimmten Infektionslast sehr gut erkennen,
Der Lauterbach hat jetzt auch nochmal so eine Studie ver.
Festgehalten hat, dass wenn äh jetzt Symptome vorliegen, also bei Symptomen behafteten, dass sie dann sogar eine hundertprozentige,
hinbekommen haben. Also an dieser Schnelltestfront, da tut sich 'ne Menge und das verbessert sich offensichtlich, also zumindest diese Test von Rosh und Abot, die wurden dann entsprechend bewertet
Ja, hoffen wir mal nur, dass die jetzt auch einen ausreichenden Mengen an Start gebracht werden. Ich kann überhaupt nicht beurteilen, woran es liegt, dass es äh nicht gemacht wird, aber.
Mal gucken. Denke im Februar werden wir dann spätestens auch hier unsere schnell schnell Testmaßnahmen äh erleben, weil.
Anders wäre der Situation nicht mehr Herr werden. Gut Pavel, lass uns äh ein Ende finden, auch wenn man jetzt hier.
Ja. Ähm ich meine.
Bisschen verzweifelt sind.
Positiv.
Ist, dass die mir die Infektionszahlen äh nicht mehr exponentiell steigen. So kann man's vielleicht zusammenfassen. Und ich habe Hoffnung, äh dass.
Zumindest ja nicht.
Nicht großartig steigen, ähm aber äh.
Was soll man sagen? Ich meine, wir haben's, wir haben's halt durch, wenn man wenn man einfach nur auf die Fakten äh guckt, dann äh besteht ja,
eigentlich nur mittelfristig äh Hoffnung auf ja nächsten Sommer mit.
Konzerten und Fußball und Ferienreisen und.
Mit deinen Fakten paar willst du mit deinen Fak.
Ja ich ja aber wer weiß vielleicht gibt's ja ein Wunder und irgendwie
äh ja klappt das Ganze ja auch noch ohne harten Lokdown nur äh,
ich finde,
Ja Politik die äh darauf basiert, dass.
Man Glück hat oder dass ein Wunder passiert ist jetzt nicht gerade Vertrauen erweckend.
Brauchen wir auch nicht. Wir schauen uns einfach die Sache in der Woche nochmal an und gucken mal, ob sich irgendwas verbessert hat und vielleicht stellen wir ja da fest, dass äh.
Alle viel kluger waren als wir und sich das schon wieder in eine andere Richtung entwickelt hat. Aber haben auf jeden Fall unser Totyou so Potenzial soweit erstmal ausgereizt.
Okay? Dann entlassen wir euch hier ins Wochenende und äh.
Tschüs.